I'm Robert Kirchner I'm the clues
professor of science here at Harvard
University and I'm using the Hubble
Space Telescope to study supernova
explosions supernovae are the deaths of
stars they're extremely luminous you can
see them halfway across the universe
they stir up the gas between the stars
but one thing that's really interesting
is that they make the heavy elements out
of which we are made so the iron that's
in your blood the calcium that's in your
bones the oxygen that you're breathing
those very nuclei were made in supernova
that exploded before the Sun formed my
favorite moment came when we saw a
supernova 1987a with the Hubble Space
Telescope the supernova went off in 1987
Space Telescope was launched in 1990 so
we were looking at it a couple years
after the explosion and we had formed
some ideas about what it might look like
but our imagination was very far short
of reality when you actually looked at
the photograph it turns out it has this
beautiful ring of emission around it
that is the result of gas that was lost
from the star before the explosion being
lit up by the light from the supernova
explosion itself it's great to see one
image from supernova 1987a but when you
have data over a long period over 25
years that lets you make a movie that
shows you a time-lapse movie that shows
you how things have changed and what's
changed is that the debris has gotten
bigger the ring lit up when the pressure
wave the shock wave from the explosion
got there and now the ring is starting
to fade which we think means that it's
breaking up and that if you come back 25
years from now you're not going to see
the same picture
and they in your house I have not only a
picture of supernova 1987a I have a
ceramic tile this is an image of
supernova 1987a made in this tile by
Mona my colleagues Dick McRae and it
shows the debris in the center
it shows the hot spots glowing in the
ring around the supernova and it shows
the outer rings and nearby stars too
it's a great feeling to look at
supernova 1987a first of all it's a
beautiful thing
secondly you understand that this is
something that you you just have never
never seen before but I think the future
is going to be even more interesting
we're going to see the destruction of
that ring and more to the point we're
going to get a better and better look
into the center we think the supernovae
formed a neutron star we haven't seen it
yet I hope that our space telescope
images will show it to us sometime in
the near future